they call those transformed by the virus
freakers jesus
are you ready to
fight hello my name is uh david lee i'm
the community manager over at event
studio for days ago
our team has been developing daisy on
for over six years at this point you
know i'm pretty sure you know we we are
so excited enthusiastic for april 26th
to come because you know our team has
put so much time
and there's so much space and they're
just so dedicated to creating such a
wonderful experience and a unique
experience
for the playstation 4. with our latest
trailer release with the sarah deacon's
wedding agency that is struggling with
the fact that you know that his life was
taken away with with the pandemic that
happened over two years ago in gang
so you uh especially with our game our
creative director john garvin has
crafted a story and these characters
that you you're going to want to play
through you know we've talked about an
every hour golden path of six hours of
cinematics and you know easily 100 hours
of gameplay so i think anyone who's
interested in a very narrative driven
story but also doesn't know you know
they don't mind driving around
a very unique setting i think bay's got
is loading in central oregon
it's anywhere anywhere really in oregon
you're gonna have to drive and it is uh
our studio they especially our creative
director john garvin was very inspired
by shows like the walking dead sons of
anarchy close to half the studio they
actually know how to ride motorcycles
and for them they saw this as a unique
opportunity to bring into our game which
allows you know different kind of
gameplay mechanics and different methods
to go around and as the game starts to
be more developed we've created more
ways to customize your bike and really
at this point i think there's so many
variations out there and you can really
just spend hours customizing your bike
and really making you do it so we're
very excited about that i think
especially with our bike and the way our
combat skill system is vanished you know
like in most games in the very beginning
you're going to struggle a little bit if
the game's going to be hard nonetheless
it'll be harder around but the way you
can allocate your skill points and
especially the way you can upgrade your
bike you can give yourself an easier
time but you're gonna have to make the
hard choice of all right am i gonna put
more credits or more time into upgrading
my skills or do can i make my ride a
little easier with the bike or can i
take some time to clear out some
infestation zones to make it so i can
you know maybe focus more on my skills
and not have to worry too much about the
bike so i can fast travel to my
communications
i think you know if you want things to
be easier in our game you're going to
take out those impedances up to pick out
all the red marking on the map to make
it to the fast travel and see less
encounters with creepers the human
threat is just as scary as freakers
because you have the ambush camps you
have people just riding by wanting to
take you out because after the pandemic
people
who survived like an outbreak they're
not going to be nice they're going to
try to do everything to survive just
like vegan is so you're going to have to
watch out for them
the dynamic weather system we have in
our game is play some important role
with game play with how you uh drive
your bike and especially with freakers
you know as it gets uh during the night
time that's when the freakers start to
roam around get more aggressive
especially when it starts snowing that's
it kind of hardens the freaking skin and
makes them gives you more health makes
them more aggressive so you always have
to keep aware of the weather on top of
just a normal strategy so you're
constantly kind of on
edge or like you're on your tippy toes
kind of figuring out what's the best
scenario
so you talk about performance formers
you can see anyone from one to twelve
because you know the
frequency they like to kind of stick
together but then you have forwards and
that could be anywhere from 50 to 300
and definitely more than 300 as well but
newt's you know we have streamers we've
actually showed off another type of
freaker in our recent world trailer uh
and i won't kind of divulge that
information but he is big bulky and if
you see him you're gonna want to run
unless you feel confident enough taking
down but there are more types out there
that you can encounter that you always
have that you know second in when you're
playing the game that's like okay do i
feel confident enough to take him down
or should i just drive away and cut my
costs
marauders are just humans that are kind
of like beacon where they're going to
pretty much do whatever it takes to
survive it's been two years you know
people who've lived past this pandemic
after two years you imagine they're
going to do anything to survive uh
regarding the rippers they are
pretty much
crazy people you know they once the
pandemic happened they believed that it
was a sign from god that this was a good
thing so they cut themselves they burned
themselves to be closer like the
freakers and they they pretty much
worshipped the freakers so anytime you
encounter them they're gonna want either
you to join them or they're gonna kill
you so you're gonna have to kill them
and they're very aggressive
we haven't shown um you know these kind
of enemy types yet but you'll see very
unique types especially within the
ripper community what's great about our
system in game is copeland's uh that's
the first thing cabin you encounter
yeah we have manny there he's actually a
mechanic so he's going to have the best
mic products but then uh in the demo we
that you had a chance to play you
actually get to join a tux camera the
hot springs and there uh alki actually
has a good managing weapon so if you
want better weapon upgrades or kind of
weapons you're gonna go to him we
haven't revealed all the camps yet but
you know that each camp kind of
specifies in a different specialty and
that you want you're going to need to
make the decision of okay where am i
going to focus doing side jobs or
turning in stuff you know at each of
these camps and i could say that in our
team has just been you know they've been
working on the been working on the game
for so hard for the past six years we're
so excited to get the
our game dave's gone into the hands of
the playstation hardcore fans and the
casual and we're just you know we're so
excited to see our game release on april
26th explore the world of days gone at
your peril